here we go seven seconds until the
warzone kings kicks off sixty-five
players 1876 average rating time
handicap here we go you HQ where is my
little timer the timer is in place it's
in place okay I want to get my bishop on
d3 I'm okay with that captured my bishop
is going to be a monster can I get that
I have the open H file pin that night or
even just jump into here get my queen on
h6 I got the Queen they might resign and
resign oh I'm dropping my knight but I'm
getting something over here this is me
soon where is that mate they resigned
back determined to Anton squared is up
there to - oh I thought I was just gonna
get paired up with Antone oh man because
we were the only ones with two and there
were zeros this guy is at negative - 15
seconds until you have to make a move
within 15 seconds otherwise I get a win
automatically 15 seconds is up the
stakes have been doubled boom back to
tournament six whoa 28 minutes remaining
Dillon efore efore in an excited night
that wanted to jump to c4 all right we
trade darks crab bishops and then I want
to target f7 no they're being stubborn
the stubbornness variation what does it
mean dude quit it
dude quit it with that I don't even know
what I want to do let's castle here I'll
take like this all right I'll take now
I'm in trouble
post up my night I need to take out
pieces that land here stop these squares
I definitely capture at the pond there
now I'll take like okay well let's get
over here I can take this pond maybe
oh that's a good move let's expand in
the center I want to kick that night
away all right he needs to go somewhere
else I was fearing b5 I thought b5 might
be good night here think is gonna be
very good he is there and I think I just
want to keep the B file closed so let's
just do this and now I want to open up
the G file if possible I want to
maintain this pollen also because it
stops that night right here okay I want
to smash through at that point like I
take this pawn if there's pawn push I
feel like I should be able to do
something if pon takes Knight I still
feel like there should there should be
something if that happens maybe they
should just take my knight in and say
show me okay they're not doing that now
it's gonna be a serious problem
this is gonna be me the Queen has to
give herself up she definitely has to
give herself up now no time I think my
knight could have been taken
successfully but it's kinda not stuff to
kind of run the calculations on that
Anton squared again again how do you
know what's coming Bishop c4 and the
Queen jumps out still try it for him man
still trying for it get out of there get
out of there
man all right I'm on that night can i
pile up on him I'm gonna keep that pin I
should have just jumped there right away
now right here I take and then I take
here no I don't have it covered now I do
no it's okay now it's okay I'm pretty
sure let's just guard stuff turn my
truck on the d-file Queen trade is going
to happen I don't even want to take that
pot on see who cares about that who
cares about that pawn
any trade oh man okay the queens are off
guess who's happy guess who is happy
flight square flight square pinned
bishop pile-up on the pin bishop mm-hmm
I'm in a pin now whoa let's get out of
that over here Knight c4 is a good
square my bishop should be doing some
other stuff I don't know
ha this is scary okay my rook if I am I
am why am I in this position okay it's
better now I was ready to move my pawn
and lanta is gonna be a fork bad okay
now my king could jump up here my rook
is finally gonna do something I promise
I promise he's gonna do something I
promise you okay over here
okay have that it's covered them I have
resign that Knight is boxed out he's
dead
good night cook tonight mate in one -
there's no stalemate and that apon back
to term in 2020 12 12 9 6 here we go 24
minutes 23 seconds Hallam efore efore is
where to go here um is that even right
could this pot just be taken
successfully okay
f7 pinpoint f7 c6 drop all the way back
so this does not come with tempo gonna
take here if pawn takes cuz that's
basically the other thing I can do f7
maybe I could just take that I'm gonna
try it I feel like that's something the
computer would be doing make reference
to the computer quite a bit
I've been playing it better I this was
not good for me to be doing okay let's
open this F file up with check and then
do this okay that Bishop is gonna be a
giant pain the two minor pieces are much
better I want to get rid of one of them
so material is even how is the climb on
the bishop as well get the rook activity
this is a potential pass pawn my deep on
its guard everything maybe even this no
g4 is probably better stop Knight move
here my rook is in a very good spot I
should get my King doing something more
the knight might look to reposition at
this square get that Bishop out there it
certainly may be gonna go after these
guys my King needs to come over here I
have this square covered I think the
bishop gets trapped if it takes the pawn
it's gonna take the pawn my King jumps
over a couple squares and it's dead all
right same thing king b2 if that happens
okay I got it
pawn push maybe best okay actually that
wouldn't work I could have just pushed
oh that Knights ready to kill me let's
take them thank you everybody the tricky
Knight get rid of that tricky Knight
oh man okay didn't realize that kid they
could take that maybe get rid of the
rooks okay anything anything at all push
this pawn no time back to turning thirty
thirty twenty twenty twenty a lot of
time remaining Monsey um okay let's try
an H pawn attack okay I could get this
in if the knight is not on f3 this could
maybe turn out to be very good okay now
this is gonna be an issue as soon as I
move my pawn it's hit twice if there's
Castle there's a problem Castle
queenside maybe I'm on the night drop
back if it's hit
was that night up to Oh getting that
night I got that night get my other
night out no matter what
getting this pawn king up and as well
get rid of that no time I don't want any
time to come out for the clock trade
nights as soon as it come no I'd get the
bishop but then there's a pin I just
want to get rid of the knight now this
is a problem my inner peace is all
coming off everything is now falling
Bishop here actually it doesn't matter
give a check anything at this point
anything at all I'm trying to weave of
me very quickly its guard my knight and
then there's potential for made on f2
made on f2 if the King goes back is he
gonna go back he did go back that's me
back to term at forty two thirty thirty
twenty three okay para twenty minutes
remaining French advance support d4 or
do I even support d4 I'll just let it be
take him and then get Bishop d3 all
right they're watching out for them I
want to get that pawn back I got him
back my bishop out to where I'm a bishop
to get rid of their dark square Bishop
if this rook and then do what control
dark squares okay my opponents doing
well to get rid of that guy oh my queen
on the dark squares that push is gonna
happen
same thing Queen wants to be on dark
squares why am I playing like this h4 I
want to get a pawn to h6
I'm okay with a Queen trade my king on
d4 is gonna be a monster he's a monster
King on d4 is a monster let's do this
and then I'm guarding that pawn and also
hitting this one I really can't take it
let's get these pounds going a bit more
one of them can maybe turn out to be a
thorn the King starts to get pushed
around and I could go in a different
direction now my king
my pawns are very fast I can maybe take
this in some variations
let's guard this pawn like this and then
now I'm ready to take that but now I'm
not my king wants to be in a different
spot let's try this square like this
like this
I need a pawn break I'm not getting a
pawn break oh my Rep playing right here
is good okay now there's a different
pawn break I could be going forward with
you put pressure on this okay different
different thing going on now King back
here this pawn push I could take with
check now I take here they're not in a
position to defend stuff guard this pond
drop back and block oh they're getting
that I could take this part and then get
over here just in time I did not
calculate that oh did I calculate that
one nope not at all oh I think that's a
night that's not a night that's
tournament that's tournament pact a
tournament 56 42 42 oh man all right
double those points c5 d5 okay keep this
tension I know how many times I've just
immediately captured it and ends up and
not a dull structure I do not want that
to happen in these one-minute games
Queen b6 I should have been going with
Queen b6 pile up our hit at b7 okay
clean here pawn push could turn out to
be very good Queen takes would be needed
all right this could turn must be a
problem after the file opens up Knight
moves probably against the Queen I want
to get castled first okay now we have
this if I'm not castled first and I do
something tricky against the Queen
there's maybe Queen a4 stuff how do I
take probably with the pot and then try
and undermine this Center alright here
we go
undermining phase
let me get my knight in a better
position first maybe I don't even need
to castle let's do this and then this
actually yeah let's do this okay they
can take my rook get my bishop but I
think I'll be okay with that
I take this my knight is a really good
piece could get kicked away maybe it's
not so bad it's in a good spot 20
seconds from my opponent I push this
bishop is pinned I can't get this
advanced in he's a liability it's not
really gonna come down to any of this
though time is the biggest thing rook b8
hit this problem I'm on that pawn twice
upon push then he's weak okay
trying to exploit this pin but there's a
pin right here that's the bigger pin oh
that was a slick move okay I'm on the
bishop I'm that Bishop and I'm gonna get
this pawn next I got the bishop okay
there is no they're down I heard they're
down on time back determined seventy two
forty five forty two forty two okay xm8
X this is uh this is a crazy variation
I'm gonna take that night I feel like
this is like a trap is it a trap
probably is you guys should have taken
with the night I just want to get
development in development development
I don't want to take that pond for some
reason I can't really put my finger on
that one don't really know why all right
that Bishop could move I want to get out
of any tricky stuff okay that night is
gonna kill me isn't he
let's drop back night right here queen
up though gotta watch out for Bishop
hitting at that square pawn push time is
close to equal Oh No that could have
taken my knight they could have taken
twice on that square they're grabbing
this pawn queen trade Queen trade over
here I'll try another Queen trade soon
on that pond on that pond twice I'm on
this pond let's grab theirs how do they
like it they grab mine so I want to grab
theirs so here we go grab this pawn King
up I want my Queen here
oh no pawn push that's Gary I didn't
want a pawn push oh that's I should
plead here that's a good move or is it
my rook gets active what is my queen
doing anything okay I could grab this
pawn with check and I want to get rid of
this one or maybe this one with check
one of them with check this one okay
King position just working out with
check grab this guy push my pawns
Clark Clark huh oh no oh no oh I want a
time to be so close oh man
I lost track of time watch out for the
Siberian trap watch out he's right
around the corner
the Siberian or a fishing pole combo
it's been a while for a fishing pole I
haven't forgot about it
hang on tricky night you know you want
to move he did move h2 how many times
have to Sage to 110 ninety-three no no
no no okay all right I clicked weird
right there okay let's go let's go let's
go let's we're all here okay
tricky stuff what is oh I just tried to
Castleton like yeah that's how you
Castle well done
what do you call that Queen side attempt
at a castle let's try this again oh man
yes everybody should try it a castle
like that at least once in your chess
playing career oh man
okay stay focused now stay focused
grab that bishop that's been there for
how long discovered checks everybody
loves those I should have been doing
that for a while
Oh watch out for made on h7 h2 and now h
7 back to tournament 130 193 90-61
11 minutes remaining TCS alright yeah T
as seed press play this guy last
tournament I think I think
okay here we go more of this more of
this this seems a little crazy what i'm
gonna do i'm gonna try g5 I think g5
actually night before is going to be
inconvenient as soon as I clean left
from her home square that's a fork
that is definitely a fork now let's do
this in the meantime maybe I could
rescue my knight I think I can I think I
can with this and then you could always
play here attack let's do it anyhow my
knight now once you get to these light
squares they're very weak and I want to
keep things closed on the a and B files
where my King is out I want to get rid
of this Knight as soon as possible the
one that's in my territory needs to go
so pawn push soon but there's another
fork actually interest grabbing a piece
this is trouble big trouble
I might want to just take that night I'm
gonna take them just get rid of pieces
and then challenge the pond that's in my
territory okay this is falling apart
fast
that's check this is gonna be a pin okay
Willian here no matter what I'm on the
knight if the knight moves maybe me hit
the Queen what am i doing I should have
just given check that would have been me
okay the knight is hit twice I'm looking
for me actually oh I'm looking to drop
pieces also
okay right here the knight is pinned
rook here next probably no matter what
okay this is me a one two three or just
one and two no matter what right there
back to tournament 150 143 118 107 nine
minutes vit Toyland alright I don't have
to worry about d5 as much when there's
that baby step with the d6 I might my my
queen on g3 and there's potential pins
right here like this pawn can't move as
soon as I do f5 let's do this maybe I
could get at f7 grab this okay now this
is a giant night I'm on the Queen they
missed it I'm not enough seven take f7
and then just get rid of the lights now
that down they resigned back to
tournament 170 143 138 127 Vinnie eight
minutes remaining
okay
open Sicilian yes still potential for
what pawn push I just have to jump here
and then build my center night there now
we're not having that so I want to put
pressure on this pawn pressure on now
this weekend point the bishop is not
there to defend if the pawn moves
there's dark Square weaknesses it might
have to come back actually there's on
castle myths no Castle ness I'm Castle
miss now would take here deflect the
King away from the Queen away from that
is what I meant now this is check and
then this is gonna be an annoying pin
the Queen's are officially coming off
the board huh no no no no no no no no oh
man I didn't mean to do that
I thought there wasn't anything my
opponent could have done this is still
okay though this is still actually okay
oh you see cuz everything I have
coordination if you don't have your
Queen make sure you have things
coordinated and everything is glued
together coordination
let's give check
um what am i doing this is bad need to
push my pawns let's just get rid of that
there's gonna be a sack okay come over
here let's come over here now
I still have coordination oh my goodness
I just dropped a rook everything oh now
it's not good now it's not good I said
it might be good now it's not good come
over here it's safe isn't it it's safe
here
Oh Oh sacks come on defend bishop keep
things closed push my pawn into Victory
Lane over here ah you're gonna grab that
pawn off anything they're grabbing
everything can I get that rook no I'm on
the rook I got the rook check I'd push
anything right here time burner time
burners is all I ever have oh yeah that
was an ugly ugly game yeah everything
was I thought everything was just gonna
be perfect I thought I could no matter
what I could take on that e 2 square I
guess it was wrong guess it was wrong in
that one tricky pins tricky pins f7 f 7
now that the pond isn't here this is a
problem or is it I can take care tricky
stuff maybe oh okay I feel like my
bishop should be somewhere else that's a
fork f7 I take this and then this I'm on
the rook f7 King takes double check me
you know I was ready just take here huh
but I could get this that's I'm making
one threat keep this right there keep my
Knight right where it's at mate in one
and then
two and then three out ready where is
that mate right here and then here there
we go back to tournament that King was
definitely looking to get central
centralization Kingslayer
everybody should fear the Kingslayer no
joke no joke if you have to play against
the Kingslayer
all right now I'm am I getting this pawn
I could take them on maybe if you're
able to attack if you're in a position
where you're attacking one of your
opponent's ponds or NER one of their
pieces twice and it's only defended or
its defendant zero you could probably
hold off with taking it maybe keep your
opponent guessing as to which way you
will take on your next turn so we are
just going to trade I'm gonna be extra
careful with my queen this time promise
not to draw my queen like that again I
want to make sure those pre moves on the
bishop twice let's just get rid of him
actually I should have kept my knight on
d4 he was very good my bishop is boxing
out the night I'm up upon I also have a
flight square and my opponent has a
flight square King improvement it's
protected and now there's no f4 there
might have been if I didn't do that
I'm gonna have f4 I'm looking to get a
pig right here pigs attack the knight
attack the knight attack the knight
watch out for checks King improvement
I'm not sure why I hadn't made that pawn
move okay I want to I want to fix this
pond right here actually I should just
take them he's a free pun take free
pawns 20 seconds from my opponent stop
the knight from getting active King
position next I could take here if
there's rook check I can come over and
attack him rook here might actually work
okay they're not doing that push it back
no matter what pawn push no matter what
keep going got a queen
no matter what are they gonna resign
hell on their clock tick they're down on
time back - chairman - 3203 - 3203 187
Bigfoot Bigfoot who is at negative 56
why is he why is Bigfoot playing now
come on Bigfoot come on you had negative
56 how'd you get there are you just all
of a sudden starting to play
I've seen these tactics before is this a
similar tactic oh I already sniffed out
these tactics is this something similar
going on I need to know somebody film
him yeah okay King position and just get
my bishop developed maybe get at this
point making one catch him in a pre move
okay open up the H file - each file is
opened my bishop could play here kick
the night away
that's check deadly bishops that's a
piece all right that's the exchange rook
here rook here I just want to exchange
pawn push I stay on this diagonal now
back to tournament they resigned okay
maybe they were just waiting to play me
or something I'm not sure okay I have a
I have a cushion in this in this
tournament not like the last one I was
fighting my way back I was fighting my
way back and that last one
f4 is f4 gonna be played not just yet
okay my knight wants to weasel around I
don't okay let's make sure I get to this
square I want to get rid of the dark
square Bishop sand then plant up on this
square e 5 ok the dark square Bishop is
gone officially gone and my night as a
monster on e5 is a very very strong
piece dark square Bishop needs to get
out doing something he's the bad Bishop
of my to work this is a got a couple
pins going on Queen h6 is my my next
spot for my clean pawn push I don't know
if I take the knight probably not watch
out for Knight b5 stuff I don't want to
allow a piece to get here to put
pressure on d6
Ace b5 is the plan from here a 6 b5 is
how I'm going to make progress okay I'm
dropping upon doing that but maybe it's
gonna be okay I get this pun at the end
of it but not really maybe they're gonna
miss that I'm actually covering this
square lateral movement is often missed
and it was missed I also have a fork
here that's been here forever Knight g5
I'm on the rook maybe I take the knight
first or not take here I could take here
next on the Queen and this pawn think I
want to get rid of this pond gotta watch
out for h7 a little bit Forks
let's just stop it before it's even a
threat and Queen tradin I get a Queen
trade Queen and Knight are being hit it
was missed no matter what even if the
rook blocks there's no time three two
one
no time back to tournament 272
thirty-eight 223 207 Vinnie this game is
not gonna finish
unless there's potential for scholars
mate nope haha me Vinnie is running wild
here where does that mean game that's
tournament first place confetti let's
close out all right
final tally 272 38 to 23 to 27 119 a
little bit of a fight there for third
place confetti land 18 games 1916 seems
like it was a clean tournament okay good
games Oh